hey guys it's justine and today we are
going to be talking about 5g now i have
a very special guest today this is
francesca sweet who was on stage during
the iphone announcement to talk to us
about 5g
and i feel like there's a lot of
confusion around 5g especially if you've
never experienced it before
or i've never had a device that is 5g
enabled all of the iphones that were
announced are 5g enabled and i'm
actually
shooting this video on the new iphone 12
pro
so this is really really exciting
francesca's also filming her part of
this video on the iphone 12
so this is extra exciting but let's get
into it and talk about some 5g
hi francesca thank you so much for
taking time to chat with me about 5g
i'm excited to be here thank you so much
for having me this must be so exciting
for you to sort of see this all kind of
just come together
absolutely we've been working so hard on
this for for quite some time
and so we are thrilled that it's finally
you know time that we can share the news
and talk about it
so far we've been really happy with the
feedback and and we can't wait to see
what comes so for the first time i was
out just taking photos and normally i
feel like i have to go actively search
and find 5g but this was the first time
that 5g speeds found me i was out taking
photos and i looked down
and i started freaking out it was like
5g uw oh my goodness this is so exciting
and i did some speed tests so i just
looked down and i was like oh
it's on 5g uw i've actually never seen
that before the 5g coverage still isn't
everywhere right now so the fact that i
just looked down to be able to capture
this
is so exciting 573 download 41.7
upload i'm gonna come down here and
tether to upload all of my videos from
now on for me like kind of having that
first experience i'm so excited for
people to really kind of get to see
what this is all like so could you just
explain to us
the various types of 5g and what this
means
to people who are just kind of jumping
on this for the first time ever
yeah i mean i think the great thing
about iphone is that every device has
the the 5g capability so no matter
whether you're
on the iphone 12 mini the iphone 12 the
12 pro 12 pro
max we have the incredible 5g
capabilities across the board in the us
we have the millimeter wave on top of
sub 6 and so
for those that don't know that's the
higher frequency version
of 5g that will allow you to do the
things like you said where you see
verizon's ultra wide van network so
you'll see that 5g
uw and so that's going to allow you to
get you know even faster speeds
even faster downloads but really across
the board we have an incredible 5g
experience no matter what carrier you're
on
because of the sub six capabilities that
we have as well
and so um it really is unlocking uh
capabilities for
folks to do all kinds of things from you
know downloading and
streaming that's going to be i think
incredible for for any carrier
so what kind of speeds can people expect
because i was actually shocked i mean i
got over 500
uh download i mean that's faster than my
at home internet i have the best
internet that i possibly can
and i cannot even get speeds like that
at home yeah i think we're seeing some
really incredible capabilities so
on uh the millimeter wave on the high
frequency version of 5g
we're seeing speeds that are up to 25
times faster than on lte
so certainly able to you know do some
really incredible things
uh and then similarly even on sub six
we're seeing speeds that are up to two
times faster
than lte so um you know everything that
you do and touch is going to be
incredible
i mean even two times faster is amazing
still faster than my home internet
exactly yeah yeah we've seen that you
know for a lot of people you you know
you don't need to connect to wi-fi as
often
this can be such a huge game changer i
think i mean for so many people but for
me as
you know a video editor being able to
upload these files and be able to just
basically essentially in the future edit
in the cloud yeah we have a really
powerful
video capability this year so now with
the ability to capture these 4k
hdr videos with dolby vision so you know
you're out in the field
all the time being able to upload those
certainly we're gonna see
um you know i think unlocking all these
great opportunities for creatives to be
able to
you know upload all of their content in
in real time so what is apple doing
differently with their 5g
than other smartphone makers yeah we've
really looked at it from the ground up
and so when we were
set out to design iphone with 5g we
looked at the hardware the software and
we worked closely with our carrier
partners and
infrastructure providers so starting on
the hardware side we
developed a lot of our custom components
so everything from
you know the antennas to some of the rf
components radio components
and that allowed us to fit even more
into our compact design
so we were able to get the most 5g bands
of any smartphone so that means that
your iphone is going to work in even
more places around the world and then on
the software side we really looked at
our entire software stack everything
from
you know the firmware to the system
layer to
to ios being able to do facetime hd
over cellular being able to stream high
quality
high bit rate from the apple tv app
faster personal hotspot we've also
introduced smart data mode which allows
us to
intelligently manage how you're using
the cellular
network so we can automatically switch
from 5g to lte
when you don't need it but then the
instant that you do we we switch back so
you're always going to get that really
great experience
and so overall just being able to design
it in combination
the hardware and software hand in hand
allowed us to
have a really incredible experience
across the board and i feel like i'm
kind of
doing a lot more intensive things than
most people would be doing when they're
getting their phones but you mentioned
just
increasing the the quality of facetime
calls that's actually something
that's like the last thing i didn't even
think about that because i'm like okay
well i'm going to be able to upload
videos faster you know post content but
just for people who are just making
facetime calls and talking to your
family you're going to get a much higher
quality
call and video signal as well and even
today you know it's more important than
ever for us to be connecting with our
family and friends and loved ones and so
to be able to get this really high
resolution
high quality high definition video
allows us to just feel even more
connected than ever
people that have never had a 5g phone
because this still is sort of new and
getting this phone today like what does
that mean for people yeah i think you
know everything that you
touch and do is going to get even better
so
you know being able to download movies
and music
you know a lot of people are listening
to music on the go so being able to get
all of that content right at your
fingertips right away
you know of course with these advanced
networks we have
less congestion lower latency and so
that's going to allow for really great
gaming
when you're on the go so you might have
seen during our keynote we
were really excited to bring league of
legends wild riff to iphone
and so being able to be competitive even
when you're
not on a pc right when you're able to do
this on a mobile device with the
processing power of our chip
you're gonna have this really incredible
gaming experience
from your iphone it's actually also a
really good point because obviously
these phones and devices are so fast
that it's like these carriers they need
to pick it up they need to step up their
game and now with 5g i mean i think
that's really going to be possible
especially with gaming because every
second milliseconds like that counts
right so imagine even when you're out
and about you don't have to be you know
at home tethered to your computer you
can you can still be really competitive
in game play which is really fun
and you even mentioned tethering as well
because you know like i was saying
before i was like my
at-home speeds aren't even that fast so
like i'm going to be finding these 5g
spots out and about and tethering and
being able
to upload my content on the go you know
when we're able to travel again and
things like that because it's
it's so fast like i just can't wait for
people to actually experience this
yeah we talked a little bit about
personal hot spots so we're able to
achieve speeds that are four times
faster than before so
like you said it's going to be even
faster than if you tethered it to the
phone so that's going to allow us to
you know really push the limits even
even on our other peripheral devices
as well so you guys partnered with
verizon do you want to recap kind of
what their announcement means for you
guys going forward
i think you know certainly verizon was
you know a great partner for us but we
really partnered with all of the
carriers
you know we worked very closely with
verizon
a t t-mobile sprint a lot of the
regional carriers because for us we want
to make sure that our experience is
great for
everybody right and so those
optimizations were really
important for us because we want
everybody who experiences 5g on iphone
to have those fast speeds
it's really exciting i've always said
this you know when apple does something
that means it's here and you guys are
kind of bringing it to the masses
i think you know we're certainly excited
to see what kind of opportunities this
unlocks you know we worked really
closely with some developers to be able
to
introduce some really interesting
enterprise solutions to be able to do
some really fun ar things you're going
to be able to you know
do some live interactions with augmented
reality that i think is going to open a
lot of opportunities
and so this is really just the beginning
and we are looking forward to
all of the opportunities that this
unlocks moving forward yeah you even
mentioned enterprise so how does this
kind of affect the rest of the industry
prize is going to be able to take
advantage of this by potentially putting
together some private 5g networks that
allows them to do
you know real-time analysis as part of
their work streams
and this also gives them a private way
to be able to have a secure
way to communicate i think this is
really going to enable them to not have
to rely
on a lot of the heavy infrastructure
that exists today
so i think one of the things that's
really cool is you guys did announce
that 5g is on every single phone so
whether you're getting the mini or the
12 or the 12 pro or the 12 pro max
it all has 5g yeah exactly so we brought
the exact same 5g experience
across the entire line so no matter
which phone you pick no matter which
color you love
you're going to get these really super
fast 5g speed
and you're going to be able to unlock
all of these incredible capabilities
that's amazing well happy iphone season
and happy 5g season
yes thank you so much you too this is
awesome i'll see you on a wild rift soon
sounds good looking forward to it thank
you so much for chatting with us thank
you guys so much for watching i had so
much fun chatting with francesca about
5g and i'm so excited about the future
of 5g and i know that you guys will be
too as soon as you experience this in
person if you guys haven't subscribed to
my channel be sure to hit subscribe and
hit the bell so you'll be alerted when i
post a new video
i also have a podcast that i do with my
sister over on youtube.com
samebrain you can also subscribe on
apple podcast or anywhere else that you
listen to podcasts there are so many
fun iphone videos coming up so stay
tuned and until then
i will see you later
you